um
and then we have uh michael jackson okay
so i mean i also like vanilla so
okay so the reason that michael jackson
is on there um is because
so as a kid
i went through a phase where i was you
spoke about this right yeah i think you
have really i feel like i've this is
weirdly familiar i'm talking about on
the podcast yeah yeah so i don't know if
i have talked about it on the podcast
but as a kid i went through this massive
phase where i was obsessed with michael
jackson
like like i i was i was weird he said
this
i don't know if i've said it in private
to you guys or on the podcast but like
yeah i went through a phase when i was
like just an obsessive michael jackson
kid like uh
i think everyone's gone through their
faces the target audience
[Music]
this was okay this is this was before
that phase but you know
regardless of what his image was you
know or what happens later in life there
were you know his music [ __ ] slaps of
course it's like yes it's vanilla but
it's it's a classic form
i [ __ ] love the song uh pretty young
thing but it's so hard it's so hard to
listen to that song
because the lyrical content you know
yeah you know how when like they're like
separate the art from the artist i do
but sometimes it's really [ __ ] hard
to yeah that that song definitely didn't
mean
that's one of those songs i'm like why
why this song is so good but why do they
have to be ruined i literally cannot
listen to that song without being like
this is great oh
yeah
and then you remember what it was oh
oh mj i feel that but like so many songs
are amazing yeah yeah yeah mj's just one
of those like artists that i feel you
could be at any party or like any
convention like yeah with with any
amount of people that could have
completely different personalities on
everything the moment a michael jackson
song consonant everyone is unanimously
like [ __ ] yet it's okay it sounds
amazing yeah i mean like i i think we
talked about this before but like i
don't think we'll ever see someone that
had the reach or was like as famous as
michael jackson was the people that's by
standing
the reason i got into michael jackson
was because my dad actually introduced
me to michael jackson i remember he
bought like a vhs of like the top 25
hits of i think it was like holy [ __ ]
anniversary i wish i had like a deep
story of every single pick i don't know
this is this is the reason i had the
pigs because i was like i don't know how
to talk about the music i'm just going
to talk about something like slumdog
millionaires yeah every single answer
has like a goddamn 10-part back like
flashback this is insane yeah so like so
like it's it's one of the weirdest
experiences where like you go to like
the countryside in [ __ ] [ __ ] bum
thailand or something like they they
don't that's like they've never
experienced internet there they barely
have electricity there you know you go
to the [ __ ] changing side and like
even going in the middle of nowhere
somehow there will be this one farmer
who will have this like old beaten up
cassette tape of like michael jackson
the thrill yeah and and like they
wouldn't they would not know a single
word of english right and they're like
oh you you grew up in england you know
michael jackson you know you know you
might
beat it and i'm not just like
how has michael jackson
how does michael jackson have this reach
well he's the king of pop right yeah
yeah yeah so so like it's like it's
still like thinking about it so it blows
my mind just how famous
one person is i think thriller even to
this day is the most sold album ever hmm
i think so yeah well i just feel like i
have any idea yeah which is like stupid
that sounds right it's like it's like
by stupid i mean like the difference
between thriller and everything else is
like stupid like true it's insane yeah
because like you know you could go to
the bum [ __ ] middle of nowhere in japan
yeah and there'll be some like decrepit
70 year old 80 year old lady you know
putting rice in the rice fields and
being like oh might get a juxtaposed
yeah
crap
just that piece of [ __ ]
they're all
useless
the kremlin wasn't the right one old
lady just
trying to give you some rice which jerry
will say will taste the same anyway
yeah who just like knows michael jackson
it's like yeah it's just everyone knows
it's ridiculous yeah yeah yeah it's it's
like weird it's like where to think how
someone one person got this famous to
like so many cultures and so many
countries that obviously had nothing to
do with the us or just like even listen
to that kind of music in the first place
and uh and and i mean yeah i mean
thriller is like i know putting like
thriller on there is kind of like
putting like you know [ __ ] zelda or
something as your favorite video game of
all time but i mean
i mean it's it's one of it's one of the
most legendary albums and he's one of
the most legendary artists for a reason
yeah and uh absolutely yeah and i was a
weird michael jackson kid i actually uh
did you learn how to moonwalk huh did
you learn how to moonwalk i attempted to
learn how to move i think i think i
could moonwalk at one point i couldn't
move at one point too yeah could you
actually yeah genuinely genuinely yeah
did you figure it out by yourself or no
no i watch youtube videos i think i
watch youtube videos okay okay because i
remember trying to figure it out as a
kid right trying to figure out how the
moonwalk works right because like frame
by frame on the video just like
analyzing the moonwalk yeah yeah because
and as as like as like a five
six-year-old kid or whatever i was like
i got this i could this looks exactly
like like michael jackson yeah and it
was only until like years later when
youtube existed and youtube videos
existed did i realize that's this is not
this is not how you do the moonwalk i
was doing it i was just walking
backwards
literally i was just like walking
backwards the inside so i'm thinking i
look cool as [ __ ] no no
i tried to do like the you know the leg
like pop thing that he does oh yeah oh i
tried to do that i tried to do that i'm
almost
i was like oh is that why he shouts out
because it just [ __ ] hurts all right
yeah and uh this japanese artist yeah so
okay
[ __ ] me
hold on just frothing over michael
jackson just slurping up so that you can
add that to the uh compilation of god
tries to drink like a human being
so i guess uh this this is with demayo
but uh this is more of like where i put
her in just because i feel like she's a
genre of music that i
have just recently gotten into yeah um
and as with everything in my life
somehow everything always comes back to
a domestic girlfriends for [ __ ]
i was like i was born for this moment
as it always does right so how i so
i'm not sure what this genre of music is
because it's not really just j-pop it's
it's like it's more of like okay so how
i would describe it you know do you know
do you guys know what utah days are yeah
of course yeah so your titans are like i
believe uh singers or musicians who
mostly originated from nico nico
starting who started off doing a lot of
like hatsune miku songs and stuff like
others yeah stuff like that so
a lot of
a lot of these musicians who came from
the scene ended up just like
i guess graduating and just made you
know start started making their own
songs with their own original artists
um and there's this i i don't know what
the genre is but there's a lot of
artists in this genre that i got
introduced to by the domestic girlfriend
opening because if okay domestic
domestic girlfriend is a very divisive
show i know that really i know that um
the opening [ __ ] slaps yeah the
openings are amazing the opening is
[ __ ] amazing
[Applause]
yeah yeah and uh so i that's how i
discovered that artist minami
um and you know spotify recommendations
usually recommendations so i i i got
really really into minami and her songs
from the domestic girlfriend opening and
that kind of introduced me to this world
of artists like zutamayo eve
um who else is [ __ ] uh yorishika i
think yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so how i
describe them is like they they are
anime music that don't have an anime
that they play to
you know what i mean yeah again like
i've listened to this i don't didn't
know their name yeah but like if you go
to my youtube you can see i've listened
this person a lot yeah it's just like
that genre of like i'm making the anime
in my head yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so like like a lot of these
artists that i listen to now have now
been picked up for like anime openings
right yes so i remember like i got into
i got into zootomar and then i got into
eve um and then i remember listening to
the jiu-jitsu class load jutsu kaisen
opening when that came out and i for the
first time in my life i'm just like oh
my god i know this band
cause i've never heard this song before
but like they have such a distinct style
that i haven't had
that i had that moment where i'm just
like i've been following them since they
weren't underground [ __ ]
that's it the i read the manga yeah yeah
yeah yeah you just wave that in front of
jesus christ
i know this song yeah it is the
equivalent of the i've read this when
the manga wasn't big right because you
know because there are so many artists
in this field that have now been picked
up for an anime opening or ending and
and like there is this there's this
feeling of like yes your music slaps i'm
[ __ ] proud of you i'm validated for
being a fan
and then i was like
like before they became the psychopath
opening yeah the tokyo ghoul opening i
was like i knew them before this oh
really yeah you do before them
also i'm a little sad because now
everyone knows eve as oh it's the
jiu-jitsu
i'm like no they're not just the jesus
there's so much more than that listen to
the rest of their [ __ ] songs
um so yeah i mean like this is i guess
that's the kind of music i listen to the
most now that's like really that's like
my weeb kind of it's really big in japan
right now especially like
yo they're like yeah